[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ترين انه وقت صدام حسين كان افضل للعراق
يعني
انا لو اقول لك افضل راح يقولوا طبعا لانه
بنته صح شاهدتي مجروحه بس يعني اسمع من
الكثير من الناس نعم ان وقتنا وقت عز كان
الناس عايشين بعز وتقدير عالي وما حد يقدر
يسيء لهم عدا انه اللي يسيء الى حاله
معينه يتمس خطوط السلطه يصبح التعامل بشكل
اخر وقد يميل التعامل الى القسوه
لكن بشكل عام طبعا بلد مستقر بلد ثري بلد
خيرات كثيره ناسها مرتاحه في بلدها مع
الصعوبات اللي مرت بيها الناس لكن الناس
كانت عايشه على الاقل مامنه على اولادها
على حياتها على رزقها بالقدر الممكن
[موسيقى]
الحريه تعتمد معنى الحريه بالنسبه لحضرتك
ايش تعني اذا تعني الحريه اللي جتني بعد
الاحتلال
بشعار القضينا على الدكتور صارت
الديمقراطيه فاني متاكد العراقي اول من
راح يجيبك قبلي حيقول لك هاي الحريه ما
اريدها
اذا الحريه تزيف وتغلف
بالاسلحه والقتل والموت لا ما اريد
هالحريه ما كانوا اسرى العراقيين الانسان
الطبيعي كان عايش حياته اقرب الى طبيعي
اذا مو مئه بالمئه فسبع
[تصفيق]